vas-y tu vas y tu vas souvent tous nos
charges est rentré dans les choses je
donc je vais la faire entrer dans la
cabine hausse assez petit stade est ce
que tu sais pas qui tu avais sous vaille
à torreilles trouvaille c'est tout dame
va disparaître c'est bon les gars
[Musique]
première disparition mais il peut faire
beaucoup plus fort que ça je vais faire
apparaître une personne exceptionnelle
même moi je sais pas qui c'est au stade
où steve ya xavi faut pas grave mon
style steevy boulay je devais boulet on
est 3 kg spéciaux chevaux pour delwit
mon gars doux tout doux sans toilettes
non mais c'est pas fini la can avec un
gyrophare sur la tête
c'est quand même et là on regardait les
y voilà et si et on peut alors et on
peut le débrancher regardez c'est
magnifique c'est au lait j'adore y est
il est superbe pointe et déguisés sont
moctar ben moctar ouane super u enfin je
vois alors retourne toi je vais te la
mettre
je vais te la mettre aux normes
et ouais a toujours le bal avec moctar
c'est comme mon frère
alors on y va en s'aggravant plus qu'à
voilà il est bien comme ça à regarder
aller tu peut contourner qu'à bouffer
shrek fauve hautot de danse avec les
stars lettre c est là il pourrait perdre
ans avec motards vraiment très bien
comme ça et franchement ça vous va très
très bien docteur bravo vous avez trouvé
votre style à ça fait longtemps vous le
cherchez plus
[Musique]